figuring out why moves are played is
much more important than just seeing
them
them played and just you know thinking
oh the engine approves and that's that
so
yeah games games are underway exactly
and
the last thing uh as you said just to
echo
the beauty of chess the discovery of
these ideas if you just
uh see them on the eval bar you know
they flatten
and they lose their beauty it's just you
you know it's like
as i've compared before you see a
basketball being shot and you know the
basketball
whether the ball goes in when it's
released part of the
fun of watching sports is you don't know
if the ball is going to go through the
net
and uh it's i think a similar effect but
anyways the games are underway
i have uh igaragan shanklin open we have
a classical sicilian
but uh we can start it at any any game
that you that you'd like robert
i just opened the same game and i saw h4
was played
so it's one of these sharp positions
where white
throws pawns at black's king and you
could push
g4 and all that good stuff but defended
sim hasn't
castled yet what does it indicate to you
daniel when you see this position like
should i just push forward with g4
should i do some kind of preemptive play
with king to b1 to get my king
away from the center how would you
approach this for white
yeah so i'll say preliminarily that
there's generally two ways of playing
the classical but why can keep the pawn
on f3ac car has
there are lines where white obviously
brings the pawn to f4
and the pawn on f3 is known as a more
obviously both of these lines are very
tactical but it's the more positional of
the two
uh white usually takes his time while
it's not in a huge rush but ultimately i
would say robert white
white is going to probably go g4 and
then often drop the bishop back to e3
you'll see that move very frequently in
the rouser and then
you know english attack style go g5 that
knight from c3
sometimes we'll go to e2 and then later
to the king side
as we'll see right here it has no other
squares but that is part of the plan and
sam
b4a5 so it's quite easy to understand
what it is that both sides are aiming
for
the knight from e2 also to d4 that's
another destination that you will
sometimes
see and it's just a race uh which side
is going to
uh strike first now last thing in
response to g4
one thematic idea is for black to go h5
and it sounds
like madness to push pawns on the king's
side but sometimes that actually slows
down
uh white's pawn stone hicario goes c4
though very interesting i think that's
still theory clearly by the speed
and the fact that sam is playing so
quickly indicates to me that it's theory
because sam
in the opening stages he plays very fast
and he plays rook to b8 and well think
about what's changed when you play c4
why he even took on bassan if he doesn't
the queen side closes down
and white will have the fun on the king
side if you take the c4 pawn
hey that's a free pawn let me grab that
with my queen think about where your
queen is it's in line with this bishop
and there's also problems on this d file
and i believe that this is a theoretical
blunder
because e5 would be played and the
points after d
takes e5 bishop takes f6 your bishop on
d7 lost its defender the queen was
protecting that piece so there's all
sorts of different tactics
in such a position and that's why
instead took on bassant
knight takes rook b and look at this
move down at 84.
playing where his king is but giving
himself this
b5 move so it's actually a positional
move and
samus h6 yeah i mean sam as i discussed
previously this guy's opening
opening preparation is second to none i
mean it's it
there's no you know he mentioned working
for team magnus and
he has done i mean he is just so
diligent in analyzing
so many ideas and he analyzes openings
very very deeply so if i'm hikaru um
it's it's a battle of preparation both
sides 17 moves and this position is
unfamiliar to me
i'm quite sure that you know neither
side would be playing that fast if it
wasn't prepper this is a situation after
all
so h6 chasing away the bishop so bishop
f4 and bishop e3 robert both seemed like
pretty reasonable option now bishop f4
could backfire
because sam could go e5 and then uh
position that bishop later
in that pocket on e6 where it aims sort
of at
white's king but i don't know it's funny
because
e e the d5 square is one that you're
often concerned about especially in
knight orbs
but because you get that tempo and as
you point out you can put your bishop on
e6
and the pawn h6 means that a bishop
can't come to g5 to secure that square
plus the queen side being open that i
think e5 is a good move
for black and hey car now thinking so he
maybe has run out
of his preparation and their idea is if
bishop takes f6
there's ideas with knight to b5 perhaps
first uh
those moves also can be played and as
you said bishop f4 bishop e3
all these are reasonable moves so car
needs to make his choice
i mean also knight b5 is has to be
considered
right in this position that's an
intermediate and i was calculating this
knight b5 attacks the queen
now it might seem to a keen tactical eye
that after bishop takes b5 bishop takes
b5
check black has rook takes b5 and that's
a key intermediate mode because after a
b
h g black has two pieces for a rook but
if you extend that line
why can play hg and i'm actually not
sure what's going on hikaru goes bishop
e3 he decides not to opt for that
uh but i don't know i feel like that was
worthy of explanation sam continues to
play instantly i mean
this is danger zone for hikaru if he's
caught in some
deep web of preparation because this is
not a position you want to go and
unprepared
and i want to point out one more line is
that if knight b5
uh say bishop b5 bishop b5 check rook b5
as we're talking about
white can actually say i know if i take
your rook you'll take my bishop one g5 i
can throw in
bishop takes f6 and now i am ready to
take your rook i'm ready to take your
bishop i can your g7 pawn's under attack
and the king on b1 isn't that unsafe
despite the open position so
there were some things with knight to b5
didn't happen bishop e3
castles and queen to b7 right sam being
super well prepared that scares me i
would be nice
very worried to have the white sox i
would be petrified because this is so
sharp and by the way knight takes d6 not
possible bishop d6 queen d6 and you get
check mated on b2
um yeah car is definitely going to do
that now the problem is you might look
at this position
well you know i'm looking at this knight
on b5 and it's on an outpost you know
where is black's attack well black has
several ideas right
first of all black can circumvent the
knight black can play d5
and open up the center also black can
maneuver his knight from f6 to e8 to c7
and the moment that the floodgates open
the levees break
um you know everything floods into
white's position so hikaru could go g4
he could start his own attack
using the h6 pawn as a hook also knight
takes d4 has to be reckoned with
yeah there are sacrifices in the e4 for
sure and honestly maybe g4
bishop c6 talking about sacrificing on
e4 i'm lining up my knight to take here
there's a problem on both diagonals the
e4
square checks the king on b1 hits the
rook in the corner and that could be a
problem and as you said the knight can
reroute up the e8 to c7 even knight d7
knight b6 at some point knight d7 knight
e5
many different possibilities for
franklin and he's playing so quickly
that
car is prep and ikaro taking his time
he's clearly clearly out of prep
sam uh is the sort of person he he
wouldn't play fast to bluff he's not a
bluffer
again i i can attest to this first hand
i've known him for
for so many years he just doesn't play
that game uh so if he plays fastest it's
preppy cargo's bishop d3 so the idea
that we mentioned
robert knight takes d4 hikaru decides to
develop a piece
and defend against that so it's kind of
a prophylactic move
and now tosses the ball back into sam's
court does he go rook fc8 does he go
98 knight c7 is it go d5 all these moves
are kind of tempting
and one thing he's got to watch watch
for is if he plays d5
then after e5 98 there might be bishop
takes h6 ideas
in the air as well oh that's a quick
counter you don't even think about that
because we've been so focused on black
attacking that bishop takes h6
is very powerful and it's not just the
pawns right you get your queen on h6
made on h7 rook h3 rook g3
with a mating attack you play f5
probably just g4 amongst other moves
looks good on bassant could be good g4
the king is just wide open
yeah it is it is and um you know it's
it's it's it's interesting because
it's interesting because one's sexy
yeah i mean i guess the question is
intuitively to me this idea of 98 knight
c7 does seem
like the main avenue to reach white's
king the b-file
one question would be do you take on b5
first bishop takes b5 bishop takes b5
then 98 knight c7 seems like an
interesting possibility and
a benefit of that is that that knight on
b5 is kind of a jumpy piece
and you would be removing the bishop
away from d3 i don't know i'm interested
in that well i mean
it's hard for me to just give up my
bishop for a night so i'm what you just
said makes a lot of sense and now i'm
trying to process
and kind of in line with what we're
saying about not using engines how i can
so when i get to a position like this i
can think differently and improve my
train of thought so bishop b5 is a move
i wouldn't want to play but as you're
saying it makes a lot of sense because
the knight
is a jumpy piece from b5 and knight e8
to c7 makes sense so he plays
after c8 after a several minute thought
which means
to me he's out of his preparation he's
in his sort of
general prep like he expected a position
like this could arise right he doesn't
know the best continuation anymore and
the reason i don't like working for c8
it's a bit counterintuitive is you
you're bringing rook to an open file
that sounds good but it feels a bit slow
and i do feel like blackboard
needs to play quickly that's a i'm just
gonna
that's definitely a bad move because
also remember this
in the event of a trade of all rooks if
you look at black's pawn on a5 that's
going to become a massive liability
right and i always point to the side of
the smaller pawn majority okay i
i do like d5 though i think uh you know
you've got to strike at some point and
you see car
going to play e5 then sam has also the
intermediate move bishop b4 to consider
right bishop before is probably the plan
to save that pawn but
i like what you were saying and just to
add on to that even if the a5 pawn
doesn't fall right away if we just go
back a half move
and we trade all these pieces at some
point white can play b4
and without pieces to attack the white
king that's an outside pass pawn waiting
to happen so
the end game is favorable for white and
that's why sam goes d5
not just giving up that a5 pawn as
daniel just saying e5
bishop to b4 for example i i'm starting
to
like white's position more and more and
i feel like rook fc is just that
tad bit too slow yes i i completely
agree
and by the way we already see wait uh
am i stupid i'm not seeing madison's
game he drew against mbl oh they just
drew that quickly wow okay oh carson
emil there we go
god yeah okay that makes sense i mean
obviously magnus qualifies and
mvl the same and mbl does as well
the two in the can okay uh so d5 the car
is thinking what is he thinking about he
is deciding whether to play e5 or
whether to take on c8 or
well taking on a5 seems perhaps a little
bit too brazen but certainly that has to
be considered he's made a move it is e5
okay now the big question is is bishop
before which saves the pawn
is it worth it maybe it puts the queen
on a better square or should i just play
98 right away so that's
not always an easy question to answer
and another thing is that the bishop on
4 does block the b
file so perhaps it is counter productive
in the sense that as good as the bishop
is on before it does
um you know it it does lessen the
immediate effectiveness of black's
battery on the b
file right so yeah
this does have some french-like
tendencies to it where you know
white would p he's on d4 and then play
g4 and g5 so you stop the counter play
and then go for an attack and i don't
know 98
is probably what i would choose just
because my bishop on e7 is a good
defender for my king as well
but it should be four bishop to b4
no but again i think sam is if i
may speak about his weakness and i
wouldn't make no mistake he's uh
eons and leagues stronger than i am in
most areas of the game but
in so far as he may have a part of the
game where he's less comfortable as i
mentioned previously
it is probably in the area of sort of
intuition right he's a
he's a sign he's a chess scientist he
likes to calculate and when he has to
make decisions fast
uh he sometimes does misjudge the
opponent's initiative and
uh certain types of positions he feels
less comfortable in so i think hikaru
dragged him into this kind of position
as impressive as his preparation was it
appears that to me
i'm getting the sense that he's going
off the rails a little bit here
and there is something that can bog you
down by having extensive preparations
that
you know that if you play well the
position is
x evaluation they're slightly slightly
better for white or about equal whatever
it may be
and you can be in a comfort zone i know
that this is acceptable for me
and then you just make a move thinking
that could be it but you don't have the
perfect approach and
i think it's sicilians in particular and
this is what we stem from here
that it can be so dangerous when you're
hanging on by a thread and you need to
find a series of only moves
but white's planned the other like
bishop a7 yeah
that's makes sense can i put the bishop
on b6 i think
and then it goes back to b8 you know
yeah so what exactly is the bishop doing
so rookie 8 maybe bishop c5 he wants
oh trade the bishops you know get
control of the d4 square as you said
sort of french-like idea
training the the good bishop looks good
all this is good but
yeah i don't know it's hard to say
because again let's not forget
sam can also take on on b5 at any point
and
hikaro has to reckon with that right
so i don't know sam can also take on c1
and go rook ca but we talked about that
i think the trade of rooks leads to a
position where white is the only one
who has serious winning chances agreed
completely
and yeah let me just look at the extra
pawn for black it's on d5 can't really
push the extra pawn for white can't push
for now
but that's the idea of diamonds bishop
c5 is trade off the piece that's
blockading my
quote-unquote extra pawn so i like this
idea and by the way
a car is about to win i think chankland
has just completely collapsed
let's see um and are there enough pieces
in the b-file
yeah i think there should be a few more
yeah maybe something on v3 and b8 would
be nice
i mean just it's a kebab right here it
isn't
stop making me hungry though i'm really
hungry man
queen h7 looks like it threatens
checkmate
i guess it resigns
wait actually what do you do after queen
seven f6 is the only move i think
or f yes f5 you just take on a5 so f6
and it feels like there's a checkmate
just yeah it's got to be something
um maybe there's some slow move let's
see
how about bishop d3 oh you're the worst
i see what you're doing or
maybe even a check first on h8 and then
bishop d3 to go to g6
i see you that looks winning that's all
five
maybe some chances but uh apparently
people in my chat were mentioning that
sam
hicaro blundered and then sam blundered
back uh would that move queen queen d7 i
think
let's see i mean but this position is
very hard to defend
in any case even if there is some sort
of hypothetical draw
i guess the point is that queen on b3 is
active and it can't quite be trapped but
i understand why you play queen d7
yeah because otherwise your queen is
trapped yeah there's the b3 square right
so maybe you can sit your queen on b3 in
the near future
and so bishop b5 is scary not just to
the queen trap but also this knight on
e8's not defended so i understand
why you play queen d7 but i can clearly
see why it's not good because look at
all the white's pieces but i don't see a
single alternative because the bishop is
hanging and if you go bishop b7
oh i so for some reason i thought bishop
c2 traps the queen but no queen d7 as
you pointed out
yeah definitely so bishop b5 queen b3
and that's actually what the likes of
hikaru
and wesley and all these top players
they find these moments
they do it looks like they're in trouble
but they find that one resource that
survives and you're like come on i had
to win
and yet there they go exactly they just
they just do you know
they find that stuff and and um
with a hundred percent certainty you
know it's not like they find it
sometimes
they find it always and that's what
makes them so hard to be thank you
to our goldfish for the for the two
months queen age h7 caro as indeed
played
i would say f5 is a better chance for
sam than f6 okay he's got f6
f5 is psychologically different
difficult bishop d3 just seems
pretty devastating cargo and queen h8
but here's the
yeah but but wait a second but now f5
and i'm not sure this
car has played this in the best possible
version wait wait wait wait not only is
there
f5 queen f8 might also be okay whoa
wait a second queen f8 bishop g6 and
then i go qe7
and my bishop protects my queen on f8
because you're trying to go 78.
right bishop da check looks like it
distracts the king from the queen has
done it
instantly oh my god queen h7
yeah but okay i'm not saying it's good
for black but f takes e5 where
why why can end up being worse there
because black's already have one pawn
he's going to be taking two taro
uh with a big and that's why the
immediate bishop d3 would have been much
shorter because literally if you play
bishop to three immediately then
the f8 square is occupied by by black's
king
right and you can move your balls holy
smoke actually where can you move your
queen
two i mean you have to go queen if you
go bishop g6 check then king e7
what i was showing is the bishop d8 king
takes it as you pointed out the bishop
defends the queen that bishop on before
finally um is worth its salt
yeah and now and you know bishop b3 to
start with it definitely was the right
way to go and
right now we see the queen to f8 and if
queen h7
f takes e5 you're definitely risking
losing this game that's for sure and if
you
take on the fate you're still risking
losing because you're down a pawn
what if uh queen h okay hikara has
played queen h7 so f takes e5 bishop g6
check yeah you gotta go king e7 bishop
takes e8
king takes it yes and black is just
winning there
right you wanted me to take with the
queen g7 and then say okay even that's
not clear
right queen f7 and the game continues
but i'm going to take with the king and
protect on my pawn so
if sam can get away with this
i just take an e5 he also has double the
time that a car does
he does no this is black may be better
here i mean
from a practical standpoint of course
sam is probably just
you know scared i want to say how
the way in which he scared but i won't
say it because it's family friendly
commentary but
something less but after f65 another
idea is to play g5
g5 hgh6 if you've sacrificed two pawns
you might as well go full shebang
sacrifice a third and try to ram that
pawn through
but i think i can hmm it's dangerous
knight f6
queen g6 check king g8 like whoa
that's a brilliant defensive idea though
because you tuck your king on h8
and i can resign the pawn is my shield
wow yeah he scared samus now what
exactly is sam contemplating here is
there anything other than f65
see that's what you need to do instead
of just rushing f takes e5 what sam is
doing the right thing here
yeah up on the clock he may have
something that makes his life easier
and by the way if hikaru loses this game
he might find himself on the outside
looking in because he'll have seven and
a
half
if judah draws and if he's able to hold
and duda will be ahead of him and then
if a double or nepo scores some points
then they pass hikaru right exactly no
this is uh
i think he got just a blunder queen that
fate is just and you found it
uh it's just a hard move to spot you
don't think that
you have so many squares that the black
can push right away
but um you know i found it though is
because i honestly didn't see bishop d8
check coming but then
once i made the moves it's like wait
bishop v8 doesn't work i saw it all
along but no idea
i really didn't see bishop d as a
concept i just thought maybe my king can
escape to e7 and i offer a queen trade
right no i think i think fe i mean you
can also try to run your king to e7
that's
maybe another option but um
sam's got to make a decision with some
time left on the clock this
may be even better for black now but but
still you could blunder mate here
so easily it's so easy to spawn after c5
there's also bishop d8
threatening made in one case wow that's
a really good point
that takes away the squares and so after
what do you do after bishop d8
um because bishop g6 is checked
e4 i guess e4 yeah just by default it's
like
no queen g bishop g6 and you won the
knight sam has made a move and it is f
takes e5
i'm just showing that winning the knight
variation that's really clever actually
the knight on e8 would be hanging so f
takes e
bishop trying to checkmate
where is the defense so e4 f takes c4
just take it bishop takes
yeah i'm gonna take bishop take so i can
just trade off yeah i trade and you
breathe a sigh of huge sigh of relief
and
go queen d6 and start pushing for a win
yes and
i don't think white's why isn't it twice
yeah
it's not it's not like the worst place
in the world obviously
all of that has just happened bishop
d848c4
okay and sam quickly finding this and by
the way that knight on a7 which was
looking good and powerful
earlier now it's just off the beaten
path over there in addition
uh can so sam again look at how patient
methodical he is he's also
probably contemplating knight to f6 here
bishop f6 king f6 looks like the king is
out of the woods but it's so scary
and what i'm trying to do is i'm trying
to get into a situation where white is
stranded white's knight is stranded
f6 does make sense honestly though it
does it does and
you know also also you can try you know
you know what else you can try is
wait a second let me think i know what
you're saying i
know exactly what you're going to say
but i'm going to say it
oh my god that bishop traps bishop h4
though but bishop h4
you're moving backwards and now like i'm
looking at the d1 square
if i take on e4 if queen d1 check oh my
god why might be lost
yeah displayed it oh holy smokes
what a fine
well no i mean i i use process of
elimination but bishop
mean at the very least black can play d
e bishop b4
and trade queens with that queen d1
queen d5 zigzag
but there's gotta be more there there
has to be more but bishop h4
seems like it's four i mean queen g6
check can be thrown in by hikara but it
doesn't really matter after king f8
sam's king is now safe which is what's
what is horrible for white
right so after bishop h4 can we find
something
i like your line d4 bishop e4 queen d1
check
king a2 maybe bishop d5 check can i like
trade there and
here's an idea and i said that's an a7
right so bishop d5 check i'll take it
yeah
take my queen gang b1 then uh
does bishop c5 trap your knight b5
no knight c8 might be five maybe i don't
oh wait a second wait a second what am i
doing queen h1 check take on h5 oh my
god yeah you think
holy smokes we're so tunneled on like
this night and
stuff but there's queen h1 takes h4
yeah oh my goodness i was just thinking
like where's my queen check it i see
queen d1 but when he went knight b5 like
can i somehow go elsewhere i realized
quinn h1 just picks up bishop
apparently there's some insane engine
move that equalizes for hikaru
oh lovely that's probably what he's
gonna find here
but he's under he's now down to two
minutes like he you know
he's probably in panic mode yeah because
not only
is he in danger of losing this game he's
in danger of not making the top eight
and then
that would be absolutely wild he was
completely winning
but he rushed i mean he just played a
little too quickly
okay so bishop h4 with life here yeah i
mean g5 apparently is the move
that five i get it but
what after queen takes bishop g5 queen
takes bishop
what what i'm so confused i am too queen
g6 check
and if king e7 you just
just casually just play down a piece the
car has gone bishop
oh the thing about this line with queen
g67 g-h
g-h i think your queen h7 check and the
king comes to d6
the bishop on b7 is hanging right but he
carries the bishop h4
okay sam with a chance he takes d takes
e4 instantly
he sees bishop c2 and igara has to drop
his as we discussed
okay so the knight is still trapped so
queen c5
comes to mind is probably a bit risky if
i can give a check
and put my bishop on d5 that king could
get mated on b1 so i'm trying to figure
out queen g1
it becomes a semi threat after queen c5
but what does white do after queen c5
does white have a single move
there could be g5 the g5 just take
it take it yeah and the knight on e8
protects g7 so h6 is scary the queen
protects g5 and
yeah queen c5 looks and it's it's easy
to see because also queen b6
but that's worse right wait a minute
aha so queen b6 i hallucinated there for
a second
would you versus queen super how do you
compare these moves it's a
very good question no it's not all right
three results are possible here that's
obvious
yeah the king nf7s black kid
has lost many positions that are a lot
more winning than this
so queen a6 by sam
oh my gosh that's a sick move
there's just no moose knight in queen f1
champion bishop d5 yeah
bishop d5 coming but what if bishop a4
ah but then queen f1 and bishop d5 and
you hunt
hunt white's king down with checkmate i
think
bishop d5 b3 would be the move and then
you play
among other things just queen g2 queen
h1 take on h4 again
can we go over what if g5 now
uh g5 okay so if i
don't take the knight because it's made
in two right of course not
i guess you take on g5 i'm just showing
that checkmate
so you said g5 takes
bishop bishop takes no there's a queen
takes a seven that's ridiculous there's
nothing
h6 queen g1 picks off the other bishop
right
the car now with a minute on the clock
he doesn't see anything i don't i think
black white is absolutely busted here
there isn't a single idea this queen a6
move
that's sick by sam sam is on a lot of
these
only moves that not just save him the
game he's the scientist this is these
are the positions he's so good at his
technique is phenomenal
and he's beaten me many times like
finding
an incredible precise sequence in these
kinds of situations
yeah no this is he stumbled right after
the
yeah and jiva hasn't played but i mean
it's the only tribe
i think what i car was intending is hg
bishop g5 queen a7 queen g6 check
king f8 and then h6 ah
well what if i queen g one check king a2
bishop d5 check b3 and then queen f2
maybe my g7
is protected so yeah no there's there's
not a single idea sam takes immediately
and he's just going to take the knight
yeah yeah yeah this is over if sam finds
these
moves and wow this is
this is insane
can you believe it this is how strong
this field is i know that everyone gets
used to magnus hikaru
wesley they're winning all the time and
they are the best rapid players in the
world but
everybody in this field they can beat
each other and so
in a 15 rounds 16 player round robin
sam shanklin is about to if he wins this
game he finishes with seven points
he's not gonna qualify but he's going to
be elated
that's a great performance and he's
minus one he's
you know just hanging in there with the
rest of this really tough field as a
wild card entrance so
that's the thing about these tournaments
is while magnus
will win many of them you know hikaru
will win plenty of them
duboff has shown fine form is dubois
even qualifying this time
he as well is right if he does exactly
and
and yeah can you hear me for a second
queen a7 played queen g6 king f8 h6 what
exact what again is the line
queen g1 king a2 bishop d5 check oh
ah you should give that that is a key
check because you want to make sure
if you played queen f2 immediately then
h7 would have followed
so all of this all of this has happened
let's give ourselves some credit we've
predicted some moves in these games
but that h7 idea just pushing it looks
like you're trying to take on g7 and
check and attack
then you play h7 you get a queen that's
just mean
yep so you got to be careful until the
very end but these
these are forcing moves the problem is
sam's going to consider queen joy that's
the first thing you look at in this and
bishop d5
first thing you look at and can we talk
about how great knights are at defending
because let's say you've got this queen
g1
k2 bishop d5 b3 queen f2 and hg7
knight g7 oh wait i think there's queen
f6 check but let's just
i can't even do that so never mind take
it back my queen on f2 covers the square
okay ignore me oh always
so sam with one more option can he take
on h6 is that also possible that's
probably not worth it
because then then oh no but then queen
h6 i know that's that would be horrible
yeah that king's not very happy because
the bishop cuts off the king's escape
queens you unplayed bishop d5 played
yeah sam's finding everything and if if
bishop b3
what if bishop b3 he's played b3
queen f2 don't play queen g2 that is the
last oh
my gosh imagine that oh god queen f2
played
it's one of those things daniel where
you think you're the one doing the
pinning but you're allowed
to discover something exactly okay so
what now bishop c35 c3 is what i was
thinking about bishop secretary no no h7
yes it doesn't get rid of me you gotta
try it one no then queen g one
oh my land so but you could why don't
you give a queen e1 check first
no queen e1 of course is way better but
bishop c3 if you play h7
queen g1 check because bishop c1 would
be great under other circumstances but
your queen's hanging on g6
right and you get a new queen but you
have no more sam has made a move and it
is bishop c3
bishop c3 and yeah it's where that works
i mean what can he carry bishop c1 okay
he does it watch out for
a sneaky bishop a3 check by the way that
could
be quite a problem to deal with yeah sam
should have gone should have given a
check first
you're right yeah that was a it was a
mistake but he takes that's
that that works that's fine well it only
works because bishop a3 does bishop b4
yeah
yeah that pawn on a5 is the hero because
that was close and now the gang runs and
it's basically over if sam can just
maintain his caution
mm-hmm bishop g7 works as well
bishop and knight and knight that's the
devil that's a devilish move by sam
that's a brilliant move bishop g7 now
and yeah if queen g6 checking the knight
comes in
such a good blockading piece all right
so queen d8
others obviously you can just dig you
know bishop f6 whatever you want to do
here is just you can take it slow if
you're sam
yes i would play bishop f6 or bishop d4
or whatever you want to do
queen b4 if anything wins queen b4 looks
good too going after the b3 pawn with a
mate
bishop f6 yep yeah you called it and
honestly
not not having a pawn is good for black
because queen a it is
yeah night up now knight f5 open eight
wins
yeah you trade queens and threaten the
checkmate down on it knight f5
yeah i feel like i know sam the way sam
thinks sam is gonna see the fact he sees
quinney and he's gonna be like
i'm not trading queens i'm gonna go for
me it's funny because for me that's the
easiest way to
trade queens i'm up a piece and a pawn i
win the game now now he's gonna go quinn
hey
you sure he's not gonna play queen g7 or
something no
queen just seven wins two and then
oh okay he wants to go down to c3 yeah
bishop c5
you keep telling me he might do
something he doesn't do it so i know
no i'm e3 maybe if the read is bishop
takes f5
i guess you get away with it but that's
a little wrist right
yeah that's that you do get away with it
though queen b
a queen e5 is another idea anything
knight e4
yeah that night which was on e8
defending the whole time it's finally
brought into the game with power
it is that night yeah exactly you know
it was it earned its keep
it's been there on e8 it's it's been
through thick and thin and now it just
comes in and it it blasts through the
position
by the way do bob is in an equal ending
against he's up a pawn but
there's not too much going on and duda
is trying to
hold on against geary tactically but
curious currently
a pawn ahead right so here knight takes
b3 or e3
it's just over e3 yeah knight b3 sam
playing clinically he's giving him zero
chances
yeah after bishop takes me through you
can make queen b7 you can yeah
well then bishop b4 ah then i take after
the bishop anyway you're right
he's nakamura has resigned wow
unbelievable
so shanklin wins he gets the 715. great
tournament for him
and he's saying i can hang out with
these really
elite players and he may have lost those
ready points to drop into 2700 but he
can play
this this guy can go